on passe à l'actualité africaine avec ce
dernier jour de cours et de lancement du
nouveau parti de laurent gbagbo
plus de 1600 partisans étaient
rassemblés pendant deux jours à l'hôtel
sofitel ivoire d'abidjan pour cet
événement qui signe donc le retour en
politique de l'ancien président ivoirien
les précisions de notre reporter sur
place il a famous où
nous allons reprendre notre chemin
ensemble c'est définitivement sur le
signe des retrouvailles d'un nouveau
départ que l'ancien président laurent
gbagbo a voulu placer ces deux jours de
congrès un rendez-vous tout un symbole
pour celui que ses partisans surnomment
affectueusement leur moody comprenait en
langue bété l'homme courageux le
vaillant alors ce rendez vous qui s'est
tenu ici à l'hôtel ivoire d'abidjan là
même où dans les années 80 laurent
gbagbo créé l es pays le front populaire
ivoirien et alors il s'est agit de deux
jours de messages d'hommage de soutien à
laurent gbagbo des messages venant de
chefs coutumiers de responsables
politiques de représentants de la
société civile et ce rendez-vous s'est
clôturée par un discours très attendu de
laurent gbagbo laurent gbagbo qui dès le
départ a tenu à être très clair un sur
ses ambitions politiques écoutez moi
j'ai fait a connu jusqu'à ma mort c'est
moi et moi ce
qui est de le souk est le ferment
je continue mon combat
ce n'est pas le problème d'un autre
ce n'est pas leur problème
il ya deux ans plus vieux que moi
fin politique ce débat là il faut
l'arrêter
il faut arrêter
c'est tout je n'ai plus la rive gauche
après avoir remercié ses partisans pour
leur fidélité pendant ces dix ans d'exil
laurent gbagbo a présenté les lignes
directives de ce nouveau parti le pp a
saisi le parti des peuples africains
côte d'ivoire et il insisté sur la
dimension panafricaine de cette nouvelle
formation politique
regardez un peu le monde
le voyait quinchon les peluches et la
chine
les etats unis
la russie le canada
se sont
[Musique]
tus champagne le visait 1 devant ses
collègues peuvent inclure tue son père
et fils absence notable celle de l'ex
première dame simone gbagbo récemment
séparé de l'ancien président et qui
compte encore beaucoup de soutiens ici
dans le pays alors lé cadre du ppa cia
affirme qu'elle était bel et bien une
invitée mais celle qui a cofondé le
front populaire ivoirien fait savoir sur
sa page facebook qu'elle est en
déplacement en république démocratique
du congo pour une conférence évangélique
quelques mois seulement après son retour
sur le sol ivoirien laurent gbagbo jet
avec ce congrès les basins d'une
nouvelle formation politique qui a pour
ambition de proposer une véritable
alternative à gauche face à un pouvoir
en place depuis dix ans